[Musica]
a quanti non piacciono gli insetti
potete alzare la mano
ecco vi vedo poco è però vedo che siete
in tanti e in effetti
gli insetti a molti non piacciono però
nonostante ciò oggi vedremo perché sono
fondamentali per la nostra sopravvivenza
e per il nostro futuro
ho iniziato ad avere una passione per la
natura e quindi anche per gli insetti
fin da quando ero bambino e quando
andavo alle elementari
uno dei miei passatempi preferiti era
quello di rompere delle rocce sul
pavimento della sala da pranzo con
grande gioia di mia mamma peraltro per
cercare dei fossili ovvero dei resti di
organismi preistorici rimasti
intrappolati all'interno delle rocce
quindi prendevo un blocco di calcare lo
mettevo per terra e poi martellago fino
a quando non usciva qualcosa
dopodiché lo passavo a mio papà gli
passava i miei ritrovamenti e visto che
lui è un paleontologo quindi studi ai
fossili per lavoro
lui mi rispondeva e la risposta tipica
era a ma questo è un orto c'era quindi è
sicuramente del periodo ordo viggiano
oppure a ma questo è un trilobite quindi
è sicuramente del periodo paleozoico è
in realtà lì per lì ci capivo un poco
anch'io però quello che mi stava dicendo
era che quei fossili che avevo trovato
in quel momento potevano essere trovati
solo ed esclusivamente nel periodo
geologico chiamato paleozoico e quindi
anche nelle rocce del quel periodo
geologico e che quindi potevamo usare la
presenza di questi organismi all'interno
delle rocce per conoscere la loro età
bellissimo quindi possiamo usare degli
organismi che vivevano quel periodo che
troviamo
intrappolate all'interno delle rocce per
conoscere l'età delle rocce stesse e
questo è possibile perché questi
organismi dopo un certo periodo di tempo
in cui avevano prosperato e si erano
riprodotti erano stati spazzati via
dalla faccia della terra
erano stati spazzati via
rimanendo solo sotto forma di resti
fossili da alcuni eventi catastrofici
come eruzioni vulcaniche o meteoriti che
avevano causato quelle che i
paleontologi chiamano le cinque grandi
estinzioni di massa
sono periodi in cui in un lasso di tempo
molto breve si estinguono quindi
spariscono un numero elevatissimo di
specie
sono eventi anche molto rari
ce ne sono state solo 5 nella storia
della vita sulla terra
e l'ultima per così dire la più recente
è avvenuta circa 66 milioni di anni fa
ed è quella famosa in cui si sono
estinti i dinosauri e i tre quarti delle
spese del pianeta
ma
quindi se sono così rare perché dovremmo
preoccuparci non ci si preoccupa che un
meteorite ti cade in testa
all'improvviso mentre va a lavorare al
mattino
è però in questo caso in effetti
dobbiamo preoccuparci perché secondo gli
scienziati
una di queste grandi estinzioni di massa
è in atto proprio ora mentre parliamo in
questi giorni in questi mesi e in questi
anni e sta procedendo a un ritmo
vertiginoso
l'unica differenza è che questa volta
non c'entrano meteoriti o eruzioni
vulcaniche ma è l'uomo la causa di
questa sesta estinzione di massa
inquinamento cambiamento climatico
distruzione dell'habitat e altre cose
stanno erodendo la biodiversità che ci
circonda
ma i paleontologi hanno calcolato anche
una velocità di questa grande estinzione
di massa di questa sesta grande
estinzione di massa
fate conto di andare in macchina e di
osservare il tachimetro per controllare
la velocità acquistate andando in un
tempo normale in un periodo normale con
un tasso di estinzione normale vedremo
una velocità di 18 chilometri all'ora
oggi invece vediamo una velocità di
230 chilometri all'ora molto al di sopra
di una velocità che sarebbe tipica di un
periodo normale e secondo alcuni anche
al di sopra della velocità tipica delle
altre cinque estinzioni di massa
ma non ho detto tutto queste stime sono
state fatte usando soltanto i vertebrati
e altri animali di grandi dimensioni che
conosciamo bene e che però costituiscono
soltanto una piccolissima parte della
vita sulla terra e nel grafico alle mie
spalle li vedete rappresentati da una
rana e tutto il resto
beh tutto il resto sono
invertebrati per la maggior parte
insetti che da soli costituiscono più
della metà delle specie che ci sono sul
pianeta
quelle che conosciamo che gli scienziati
hanno identificato
sono circa un milione che sono già
tantissime ma si stima che ce ne sono
almeno altri 6 milioni che sono ancora
da scoprire
di queste specie non sappiamo quasi
nulla
non sappiamo neanche che esistono e
quindi non sappiamo neanche dove vivono
cosa mangiano quale sia il loro ruolo
per l'ecosistema
i singoli individui quindi singoli
insetti sono ancora più numerosi e si
stima che per ognuno di noi per ogni
umano presente sulla terra ce ne siano
200 milioni sono cifre da capogiro
eppure sono anche gli insetti che si
stanno estinguendo
è un ritmo che non è inferiore a quello
degli altri gruppi animali
ma
quindi abbiamo detto che ne sappiamo
poco degli insetti ed è pure ne sappiamo
abbastanza per dare alcuni numeri per
esempio sappiamo che già oggi la metà
delle specie di insetti sul pianeta è
già a rischio di estinzione e che ogni
anno ne perdiamo circa l'uno per cento
ma l'uno per cento ci può sembrare una
cifra da poco un piccolo numero
eppure se ne perdiamo l'uno per cento
ogni anno
da qua a pochi anni rischiamo di non
averne più
molto meglio direte voi senza insetti
sarebbe un paradiso non bisognerebbe più
preoccuparsi delle zanzare mentre
friggiamo il gnocco fritto in giardino
d'estate
e non ci sarebbero più tantissime
malattie come la malaria la dengue
lasica la febbre gialla
vi faccio una domanda
cosa avete mangiato stamattina a
colazione per chi non se lo ricorda mi
dicono che c'è il medico che aspetta
fuori quindi o per primo ovviamente dopo
lo vado a vedere
facciamo un questionario in quanti di
voi stamattina hanno mangiato cioccolata
o qualcosa che conteneva cioccolata
bene la cioccolata e prodotta a partire
dai semi della pianta del cacao
che riesce ad essere impallinata solo e
soltanto da questi piccoli moscerini del
genere forse pò mi sa che sono gli unici
che riescono a farlo e quindi sono gli
unici che riescono a permettere alla
pianta del cacao di produrre i suoi
preziosi frutti
quanti invece di voi hanno spalmato
della marmellata sul pane stamattina
bene
allora la marmellata è prodotta a
partire da alcuni frutti di piante che
sono soprattutto rosa c'e e che sono
come pruni peschi media eccetera
impollinate per la stragrande
maggioranza dei casi dagli insetti come
bombi coleotteri o apoidei in generale
come quello che vedete nella foto
infine quanti di voi hanno messo del
miele nel tè e il caffè o nella tisana
in quello che bevete
bene il miele come è noto è prodotto a
partire dal lavoro delle api domestiche
delle apis mellifera e di pochissime
altre specie di api che l'uomo appunto
addomesticato
insetti ci nutrono ci danno da mangiare
in un futuro non tanto lontano
potrebbero essere proprio loro che
mangeremo
gli insetti contribuiscono alla
biodegradazione ovvero allo smaltimento
delle sostanze organiche
insetti sono alla base
dell'alimentazione non solo per noi può
darsi nel futuro ma sono alla base
dell'alimentazione per milioni di altri
organismi sulla terra gli insetti quindi
sono numerosissimi
ed è anche per questo che sono tra le
colonne portanti degli ecosistemi della
terra
io non capisco niente di informatica
però mettiamo il caso che voglia fare
delle modifiche al mio computer
beh lo aprirei e poi cercherei di
mettere mano a quel groviglio
complicatissimo di chip processori e
saldature che c'è all'interno di un
computer
però come vi ho detto non capisco niente
di informatica
quindi il rischio è quello di romperlo e
lo romperei quasi sicuramente
beh questo è quello che stiamo facendo
oggi alla terra la stiamo aprendo e
stiamo mettendo le mani nel groviglio di
biodiversità e degli ecosistemi di cui
non sappiamo quasi nulla e il rischio è
quello di rompere di spaccare gli
equilibri delicatissimi che ci sono al
loro interno
in italia però rispetto ad altri paesi
del mondo siamo fortunati
l'italia è il paese più bio diverso
d'europa ovvero il paese che è più ricco
di specie animali e vegetali in italia
vivono
57.468 specie di animali e
9789 specie di piante
tra gli animali una specie su dieci è
endemica ovvero vive solo e soltanto nel
nostro paese e in nessun'altra parte del
mondo
in più tra queste specie endemiche
alcune vengono definite dagli scienziati
steno endemiche ovvero vivono solamente
in piccolissime porzioni di territorio
come una piccola grotta o addirittura un
pascolo sulla cima di una montagna come
questo coleottero che abbiamo scoperto
tre anni fa in abruzzo
questa biodiversità
ricchissima che abbiamo oggi è in
pericolo e oggi abbiamo l'opportunità di
fare qualcosa per proteggerla
ma quindi
cosa stiamo facendo per ora per
proteggere questa biodiversità
poco stiamo facendo davvero poco
però quello che abbiamo fatto
sono dei simboli e soprattutto ci dicono
qual è la giusta direzione
per esempio l'italia è il primo paese in
europa che si è dotato di una lista
completa delle specie animali e vegetali
che vivono all'interno del suo
territorio
ed è anche per questo che ho potuto
darvi questi numeri stasera in più
l'otto febbraio di quest'anno del 2022
la conservazione la protezione della
biodiversità e della natura sono entrate
a far parte della costituzione della
nostra repubblica
questo però non basta
questo non basta se vogliamo
proteggere gli insetti e salvarli
dall'estinzione
dobbiamo assolutamente fare di più
dobbiamo fare di più e soprattutto
dobbiamo imparare a conoscere quindi a
rispettare e quindi anche ad amare gli
insetti perché dalla loro sopravvivenza
dipende anche la nostra sopravvivenza e
il nostro futuro
quindi la prossima volta che in giardino
vedrete zampetta re dei coleotteri dei
bruchi o delle api non passate subito
con l'insetticida per eliminarli e
pensate che salvando loro state salvando
un po anche voi grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]